La península de Corea está que arde y
los tambores de guerra con su atronador
sonido retumban sin parar.
Sí, es
verdad no es que esta zona del mundo sea
por lo general precisamente tranquila
pero lo cierto es que hacía mucho que
no se vivía tanta tensión. Estados Unidos, que ya tenía unos
30.000 soldados en la zona, ha desplegado
además varios portaaviones, bombarderos
B1 con capacidad nuclear e incluso
un avanzado sistema anti misiles en
Corea del Sur, tan avanzado que China lo ha considerado como una amenaza para su
propia seguridad .
Corea del Norte por su parte no cesa de
realizar nuevas pruebas con misiles
balísticos y de avanzar en su programa
nuclear. Sí, a Corea del Norte le da
igual hacer volar por los aires
toda la legislación internacional sobre
proliferación y ensayos nucleares.
Japón y Corea del Sur, por su parte, se
preguntan estos días, muy tensos, qué
pasos seguir y qué decisiones tomar
para tratar de frenar la creciente
amenaza que cada vez más representa la
agresiva conducta del régimen de Kim
Jong-Un.
Lo vimos hace poco aquí, en VisualPolitik, Japón está considerando muy en
serio poner fin de una vez por todas al
carácter pacifista de su constitución
E incluso todo apunta, porque esta vez es
completamente diferente a otras, que en
Pekín empiezan a estar hasta el gorro de Pyongyang.
Vamos, que si todo esto fuese una
película saldrías del cine pensando
que al guionista se le fue la mano con
la dosis de ficción.
Ahora bien, ¿qué está pasando? ¿Qué
podemos esperar? Vamos a verlo en este
vídeo pero antes de naa cobremos un
poco de perspectiva
Corea del Norte es una especie de
pesadilla del pasado, un país que vive
en plena guerra fría, que padece uno de
los gobiernos más totalitarios del
mundo y que además es uno de los
países más pobres del planeta.
Según Naciones Unidas
dos de cada cinco norcoreanos sufren
desnutrición, claro que eso parece
importarle poco o nada Kim Jong-Un, el
tipo que controla el país con mano de
hierro.
Pues bien, se calcula que Pyongyang
comenzó a desarrollar su programa de
armas nucleares
allá por los años 80 y desde entonces
ha vivido tres momentos claves que han
acelerado sustancialmente su desarrollo:
la caída de la Unión Soviética en
1991;
la inclusión de Corea Nel norte por
George Bush en el llamado "eje del mal" en
el 2002 y la llegada de Kim Jong-Un al
poder en 2011. Vamos podemos decir que
cada vez que el régimen se sintió
amenazado pisó el acelerador pero esto
lo vamos a ver un poco más tarde.
El caso es que a día de hoy se estima
que Corea del Norte tiene entre 10 y 20
armas nucleares; y según la Corporación
Rand de no pararse el programa Corea
del Norte podrá llegar a tener en 2020
unas 100 bombas nucleares.
Pero, esperad un momento, porque aquí no
acaba todo.
De momento la tecnología que utiliza
este país es como decirlo, rudimentaria, en tanto en cuanto deriva de
viejos diseños de la etapa de la Unión
Soviética, lo que hace que las bombas
que Corea del Norte ha desarrollado
hasta ahora sean poco operativas.
Por eso el régimen de Kim
jong-Un, el régimen de Pyonyang tiene
actualmente dos obsesiones: por un lado
conseguir miniaturizar estas bombas, es
decir, me explico, reducir su tamaño para
poder ensamblarlas en misiles.
Por otro,
desarrollar misiles balísticos capaces
de atacar objetivos a miles de
kilómetros de distancia.
Y, ojo, amigos, las últimas pruebas
muestran avances muy importantes en este
objetivo.
Muchos analistas, incluidos los servicios
de inteligencia de Corea del Sur y EEUU, consideran que Corea del Norte tiene ya
capacidad para equipar con cabezas
nucleares misiles de corto y medio
alcance, lo que le permitiría alcanzar
Corea del Sur y Japón.
Y esto no es todo, parece bastante claro
que de no pararse el programa en pocos
años Corea del Norte podría conseguir
la capacidad de atacar con misiles
balísticos a los mismísimos Estados
Unidos, lo que ya de entrada
supone, como os podéis imaginar, un gran
salto estratégico. Y esto os aseguro es
una línea roja que genera muchos, muchos
dolores de cabeza en el pentágono.
Ahora bien, puede que os estáis
preguntando, ¿pero es que Estados Unidos
no ha hecho nada para frenar a este
país? Pues lo cierto es que ha hecho
casi de todo
Durante años, tanto Estados Unidos como
Corea del Sur han tratado de convencer a
Pyongyang de que abandonasen su plan
para desarrollar armas nucleares y para
ello, la verdad, no han tenido reparo en
tirar de talonario.
A principios de los 90, concretamente en
1994, Bill Clinton firmó el llamado
"Acuerdo Macro" por el que Corea del Norte
se comprometió a suspender su plan
militar a cambio de recibir de Estados
Unidos una generosa ayuda en combustible
y la asistencia para construir dos
reactores nucleares para uso civil.
Es
decir, con este plan Corea del Norte
conseguía la energía necesaria para
poder desarrollar su economía.
Por su parte Corea de Sur, además de
entregar ingentes cantidades de ayuda,
humanitaria se comprometió también a
impulsar y financiar programas de
desarrollo económico en su vecino del
norte, como zonas industriales.
Y, todo parecía muy bonito al menos bueno para
todas las partes.
Sin embargo, en 2002 todo se vino abajo
cuando George Bush se enteró de que
Pyongyang le había estado tomando el pelo a Washington. Corea del Norte
continuaba desarrollando en secreto su
programa nuclear para usos militares.
Pues bien, tras varios tiras y aflojas, en
2007 se llegó a un nuevo acuerdo y la
Administración Bush reinició la entrega
de ayuda y levantó sanciones. Pero, al
poco tiempo, tan sólo un año después
Pyongyang rechazó seguir adelante.
A pesar de todo, Barack Obama lo
volvió a intentar y en febrero de 2012
se llegó a un nuevo acuerdo por el que
Corea del Norte suspendía su programa y
Estados Unidos reiniciaba otra vez las
ayudas económicas. Esta vez Pyongyang
rompió el acuerdo sólo seis semanas
después.
Llegados a este punto puede que os
estéis preguntando ¿Por qué tanto
empeño en tener armas nucleares?
El régimen de Kim Jong-Un  lo tiene muy
claro y, amigos,
hagámonos a la idea, Corea del Norte
no se va a desprender de su programa
nuclear, ¿por qué? Primero porque lo
considera indispensables para su
superviviencia, Kim Jong-Un y la élite
que gobierna Corea del Norte sabe que
con armas nucleares de por medio
ninguna potencia extranjera,
especialmente Estados Unidos, se
atreverá a intervenir en el país.
Cuando Estados Unidos invadió Irak los
líderes norcoreanos tomaron nota.
Para ellos el principal error de Saddam
Hussein fue no estar equipado con
bombas nucleares y armas de destrucción
masiva.
Lo mismo pensaron cuando cayó el
régimen de Gadafi en Libia, que unos
años antes, en 2003, había desmantelado
voluntariamente su programa para
desarrollar armas de destrucción masiva.
Es decir, los líderes norcoreanos
piensan y, probablemente tengan razón,
que las armas nucleares son hoy por hoy
su mejor garantíapara continuar en el
poder. Por otro lado la venta de equipos
militares es una de las principales
fuentes de divisas del país, divisas
necesarias para que los gerifaltes puedan
mantener su tren de vida.
Pues bien, atentos, desde que cayó la Unión
Soviética
Corea del Norte se ha convertido en uno
de los principales exportadores, equipos,
tecnologías y componentes de misiles.
Asimismo, todo apunta a que este país ha
vendido también tecnología nuclear a
Irán y que ha asistido a Siria en la
construcción del reactor nuclear
que Israel bombardeó en 2007.
Precisamente este riesgo de
proliferación es una de las grandes
motivaciones que Estados Unidos tiene
para tratar de frenar a Corea del Norte.
La otra gran motivación, evidentemente,
es impedir que este país tenga capacidad para amenazarles con armas
nucleares. Pero, dicho esto, ¿y China? ¿Qué
piensa China de todo esto?
Una cosa tenemos que tener muy clara: sin
el apoyo de China, Corea del Norte nunca,
nunca habría llevado a cabo su programa
nuclear. Y no sólo por lo que se refiere
a la parte tecnológica o al apoyo para
evitar las sanciones internacionales
sino también por el dinero.
Más del 90% del comercio de Corea del
Norte es con China.
En otras palabras, sin el apoyo de Pekín
hace ya tiempo que este país hubiese
colapsado.
Ahora bien, hay claros indicios de que
Pekín empieza a estar un poco hasta las
narices de tanta provocación y lo de
los misiles nucleares tampoco parece
hacerles mucha gracia.
Tal vez se pueda decir que para la China
de Xi Jinping, Pyongyang ha pasado de ser
un elemento de presión a un lastre
ahora que China quiere ganar peso y
liderazgo en la agenda internacional.
Ojo, por su parte otros analistas han
llegado a plantear que Pekín puede
estar perdiendo control sobre el
gobierno de Corea del Norte
ensimismado con su nuevo poder nuclear.
El caso es que, por primera vez, en noviembre
de 2016
China suscribió plenamente las
sanciones internacionales contra Corea
del Norte.
Por si fuese poco, en los
últimos meses China ha prohibido la
importación de carbón desde Corea
del Norte y la exportación de gas a
este país; lo que en círculos
internacionales ha generado cierta
expectación: es todo un castigo al
régimen de Kim Jong-Un.
Y aún más, las relaciones diplomáticas
entre ambos países están en su peor
momento. De hecho desde que Kim Jong-Un llegase
al poder no se ha celebrado ningún
encuentro bilateral al máximo nivel y
las visitas oficiales de altos
funcionarios entre ambos gobiernos se
han desplomado. ¿Será que pekín está
cambiando su relación con Pyongyang?
Aún es pronto, amigos, pero desde luego que nadie se llame a
engaño.
De momento China no va a dejar caer a
Corea del Norte que sigue siendo su
único gran aliado militar en la región.
Al menos mientras no existan
contrapartidas de peso...y tal vez este
sea el punto clave si queremos encontrar
una salida a esta crisis.
Digámoslo claro, hay que convencer a Xi Jinping de que haga desistir a Kim Jong-Un
de sus empeños, de que suspenda el
programa nuclear norcoreano y de que
lleve a cabo reformas reales.
Esto es algo que nunca se va a conseguir
con coacción,
así que muchos expertos defienden que
ha llegado la hora de plantear el
repliegue de las tropas de Estados Unidos en Corea,
poner sobre la mesa el desmantelamiento
del sistema antimisiles y también otras
contrapartidas económicas.
Todo siempre
y cuando, claro está, China consiga
frenar a Corea del Norte. Por si acaso,
tal vez convendría dejar claro a Pekín
que la situación actual
abre la vía para que Corea del Sur y
Japón puedan querer explorar no
sólo la vía de la carrera
armamentística, sino también, ojo, la de
las armas nucleares. En cualquier caso
este es un rompecabezas con difícil
solución, y como ya nos alertaba
nuestro amigo Martín hace muy poquito
tiempo en nuestro mundo aún hay
demasiadas armas nucleares.
Por cierto, si quiere saber más sobre
este tema te dejo un link al final del
video. Turno para vosotros, amigos, pinchad
aquí para dejarnos vuestra opinión en
esta encuesta, ¿qué pasos crees que debe de dar
la administración Trama? ¿Debe dejarle
a Corea del Norte proseguir con su
siniestro plan nuclear? ¿Amenazarles con
la guerra? ¿O explorar la vía china?
Publicaremos los resultados en nuestra
cuenta de twitter de VisualPolitik,
así que no te olvides de seguirnos.
Como siempre si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo, pulgares arriba, dale
a like y suscríbete al canal
si aún no lo has hecho. Un saludo y
hasta la próxima